[Music]
I just got a message about this great
project this device would help millions
of people in the rehabilitation process
consumer saving money and investors
earning but there's a problem
ideas need opportunities and investors
to make them happen so how can we help
come follow me this is the invest you
portal it works like an online
speed-dating platform for you project
and investors worldwide and finds the
perfect match and what is really great
about it it's free easy to use safe
one-stop shop with no middleman and it's
not only for big project even small ones
can the body I just found a match
there's a potential investor so are you
an investor or project promoter and do
you want to try then all you have to do
is register the next success story
maybe your